so much of our communication is about
motivation motivating others and
motivating ourselves
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
i am really excited to speak with such
huang an associate professor of
marketing at stanford gsb
suchi's research focuses on motivation
science and shared goal pursuit she
studies things such as competition
healthy eating and dynamic feedback
hi suchi welcome to the podcast i am
super excited to have you here
thank you matt it's so good to be here
excellent let's go ahead and get started
in preparing to speak with you i
reviewed a lot of your work and i'm
struck by the variety of your research
from advertising to robots and goals and
competition i'm curious what motivates
the research you do
yeah that is a great question to start
because definitely i have pretty broad
interest i actually started getting
intrigued by the topic related to
motivation because i was working at an
advertising agency jwt back in taiwan
and at that time in advertising the
biggest question is how do we motivate
our customers to come back to the store
to purchase more products and i realized
we don't really have a lot of answers
about that
and that eventually motivated me to join
academia and therefore i do a lot of
projects related to motivation and goal
pursuit uh talking about how people's
motivation could change from one stage
to another or how we potentially
collaborate or compete when we are
working on goals together
and then because of that through my
students i started branching out to look
at other types of motivation such as how
do we motivate donors to donate money or
to volunteer and also looking at how new
technologies shape our motivation for
instance the use of fintech
service robots all these new
technologies can affect our motivation
in the sense that it can increase our
motivation to do the things we love or
sometimes decrease our motivation and
that's why i started looking into these
other areas
it's so exciting the things you study
and i i love that the story comes from
your your own curiosity and need when
you were doing advertising to see that
we just didn't know enough about
motivation and we'll get to talking
about motivation soon for sure
we did a series of podcast episodes
where we talked about communication and
decision making and decision science
with some of our gsb colleagues
and you teach a class and i love the
name it's called the brains and guts of
decision making can you share one or two
key ideas that you cover in that class
definitely so the brands and guts of
decision making i teach that with
jonathan laboff so we are co-directors
of the program so he takes care of the
brain part and i take care of the gut
part because i'm a motivation scientist
and the two main takeaways i have for
students in that class is the first
thing is that it's all about the needs
so in order to think about how we shape
people's behavior it's about
understanding what needs they have and
oftentimes when we think about a company
or a product we kind of easily zoom into
one needs we believe people have but
it's actually way richer than that so i
give an example of nike nike sells shoes
and shoes satisfy one knee physiological
needs so we don't have to hurt our foot
when we walk
but of course that's way more than that
nike also sells self-esteem needs social
needs so you can jog with others share
data self actualization needs because
through jogging you become fitter closer
to your ideal self so the knees can be
all kinds of needs and it's about
picking up the right motivation to speak
to your target audience so that's the
first takeaway usually i hope our
students will have
the second one is closely tied to needs
and motivation is emotionality
because when our needs are satisfied we
get happy so there's a lot of positive
emotion there but when they're
dissatisfied that's when we get really
mad and grumpy so we have a lot of
negative emotion
recent research showed that emotionality
is really key in all our decision making
researchers were able to find that
emotionality behind the reviews actually
account for way more variants than the
content of the reviews so they were able
to actually link the emotionality behind
the reviews to predict the success of
thousands of movies billions of books
and restaurant reservations so it's not
so much about what the reviewers
actually write about but the
emotionality behind the reviews that
drives people's decision and so
motivation emotionality these are the
two things i want to highlight
wow well when i look at my nike shoes
sitting in the corner and the fact that
i haven't run in them it sometimes makes
me feel bad but but i
i find that fascinating so when we talk
on this podcast a lot about knowing your
audience and we talk a lot about their
needs and many of us when we start our
communication we start from the wrong
place we start from what do we want to
say rather than thinking about the needs
and what i like about what you've said
is you have to uncover all of the needs
it might just not just be one thing and
that's fascinating and the other aspect
you said about the emotionality so it's
not
even so much what you say but it's the
emotion behind it that we're decoding
and reading and can be motivational
really really interesting and i find
that to be true for myself when i when i
read a review of a restaurant or a book
i am taking away how did that person
feel about that definitely and it's
really fundamental because that's how
human beings connect and that's why we
categorize it as the gut reaction that's
a lot of times the key indicator of our
perception attitude and behavior oh
that's great and and jonathan was on
recently and he shared fantastic
insights too i can only imagine your
students take away amazing things from
both of you you also did research that
looked at what you call information
avoidance can you share what your
findings were and discuss how choosing
to avoid some information can affect our
motivation
definitely this is actually one of the
most fascinating findings i have
discovered and also one of the most
personally relevant so in the modern
days we know we have all kinds of social
information i log into facebook linkedin
twitter instagram i get to know what all
my friends and colleagues are doing
and so it's really an era where we have
way more social information than we need
from the motivations perspective what
that means is we get all kinds of social
benchmarks we know how much progress
other people are making and goals very
similar to our own could be health goals
family time goals or career goals
and what we found in this research is
that we don't always want that
information
so specifically when we are starting to
work on the new goal we love that
information because we want to learn
from what other people were doing and we
want to learn from their success
also as we get close to actually
reaching our goals we are usually
feeling great about ourselves so at that
moment we don't mind having those
informations because it could help us
feel like we are doing great and we are
winning and that feels great but what
really is critical is halfway through
our goal pursuit process that is the
moment where we kind of we lose
curiosity we don't really feel we need
to learn more about the goal anymore we
are not fully confident that we can
achieve our goal yet so we are not in
the late stage so that halfway point is
when we have a lot of insecurity we are
losing a little bit motivation there and
that moment we don't want to know how
well other people are doing so that is
when social information becomes really
threatening and that is when we want to
avoid it
but what we found is that if you give
people a choice to actually avoid
information they can mute the
notification move their eyes away from
the source of the information
what happens is they now don't have the
benchmark that actually motivates them
so information avoidance can actually
lead to decreased motivation
and so after i found that i use that
piece of research to remind myself so
whenever i work on my goals and i feel
really stressed out and i feel that
other people are doing great
better than me i want to avoid the
information those are the moment i
realized actually i shouldn't be afraid
i should actually see those information
because that will give the benchmark i
need to motivate myself to move forward
so that is kind of the key learning i
personally have from that research i so
relate to that be i i'm by nature i'm a
competitive person and
when
i i get really excited with friends and
others and we're gonna go embark on this
if it's if it's doing some kind of
exercise or losing weight and and after
i've been doing it a little while i do
get that insecurity like can i keep this
up is it gonna go and then when i see my
friends making more progress and of
course they're very proud to share that
progress
it makes me feel really bad and i do
tune it out but what i'm hearing you say
is that i should go against that desire
to tune it out and actually use it to
keep that motivation going what we found
is that the moment that we feel the most
insecure about having social information
it's the moment where those information
really is valuable to have oh i love
counter-intuitive things and i'm going
to try that because i'm i'm i'm got some
friends and we've got this little thing
around health going on and i'm going to
i'm going to dive back in because i've
muted some of that information so thank
you for that we'll see i'll check in
with you in a little bit we'll see how
how much it helped i look forward to
hearing your progress on that match okay
now i even more pressure no it's all
good it's all good can you share what
your research suggests are some concerns
and best practices for designing
motivating competitions so i have work
that more directly look at actual
compositions zero-sum games where there
is an incentive or reward and you have
to beat others to get it and based on
the research we do know that competition
definitely increases motivation it makes
attaining the goal more valuable
but what prior research hasn't looked at
is is it better to be ahead or behind
when you are in the competition
so we actually look at all kinds of data
sources from working out to class
performance and what we found is that
both winning or losing can motivate you
but they motivate you at different
phases of the competition
so in the beginning of the competition
usually at that moment we are looking
for signal that we can actually win so
we're doing some kind of probability
assessment if there's no chance of
winning we would just disengage instead
of investing more resources into it so
these kind of winning signal or feeling
that you are ahead is so helpful in the
beginning if you are already losing in
the beginning you will just keep up
but winning signal doesn't always work
as you get closer to the late phase of
competition if you're still winning then
the natural tendency is you relax you
feel like you don't need to work hard
anymore and we forget about the fact
that this is not an individual goal it's
a competitive goal and you have no idea
what your opponent would do in that last
stage or last round of the game
so usually in the later phase being
behind slightly is actually way more
motivating because it gives you a very
clear benchmark to achieve
so what do you do if you're actually
winning the whole way through
what we did in one of the experiments is
we actually ran a used book donation
drive it's a donation competition across
two campuses in china so you naturally
have a winning campus that is doing well
and a losing campus a few weeks in they
were collecting books but not so great
so what we did is of course we told the
losing campus that they are losing and
they increased their effort but we also
want to motivate the winning campus to
continue donating used books
so what we did is we instead of telling
them they are winning we compare them to
their campus past performance last year
so yes you are winning but comparing to
how many books you were able to raise
last year you are slightly behind of
that benchmark it is a self-comparison
benchmark but turns out even that
comparison can be meaningful to motivate
the winning campus to continue donating
books
so that could be an important takeaway
for all of us who are listening to the
podcast who are winning right now it's
great to wind and it sends a great
signal to help you stay motivated but if
you feel like you are actually
demotivated by that signal because it
doesn't seem that you need to put any
more effort maybe comparing to your past
self could be another way to motivate
you
well i like i i really like that there
are different
points of comparison and different types
of comparison to motivate and as people
who design
competitions if you will we can actually
build in some of these metrics the
information that we give to people can
be really interesting i think of
business leaders who might be trying to
motivate internal teams or across
different companies how we might give
them feedback in a way that keeps
everybody motivated regardless of if
you're ahead or behind we actually talk
to uh companies a lot and also schools
you have students who are performing
well or sales teams who are performing
well and you really don't want them to
relax they should try to achieve more
but you also can take away the message
that they are indeed winning compared to
their peers so it is important to
actually change the benchmark for those
people so they have something to strive
for
right and and one other point you made
that really stuck with me is is if you
feel like you're losing early on you
just give up so that's an important time
period to give some motivational
feedback so that you can keep people
going because i've seen that happen i've
been an assistant coach on some of my
kids teams or i've seen that in
companies where i've worked where if
people don't feel like they have the
skills right off the bat they just check
out that's why we always say that in the
early stage the most important signal is
attainability signal people need to
believe that the goal is attainable or
the competition is winnable so they will
continue working hard and so like you
say we can't just think about giving the
same feedback to everybody for the
people who really need that
attendability signal we need to kind of
give them different feedback so that we
encourage them from the perspective that
yes what you have can actually help you
achieve the goal stop comparing to other
people maybe think about what the
ability uid have learned or skills you
have so like highlighting the tenability
is going to be critical in the beginning
and somehow creating that benchmark that
additional goal to strive for additional
comparison to strive for that would be
important at the end
it's striking me in several things that
you've shared with us that
there are general principles but it
comes down to really tailoring your
motivational approach based on different
people's needs and their individuality
and i've heard you say that several
times and i think that's a really
important takeaway for all of us is that
there's general guiding principles but
what you know about the individual or
the team
really drives the tailored communication
that you have to them the biggest part
of my research finding is on the
temporal dynamics of goal pursuit and
the important aspect of this is in the
past we tend to think about what
motivates people as a static thing so if
i figure out one variable one factor i
just give that to everybody
but the temporal dynamics model say that
it should be dynamic the feedback we
give people should be dynamic depending
on who they are what skills they think
they have and where they come from and
also as they make more progress during a
competition or pursuing their personal
goal the feedback should be dynamic as
well we can't keep on giving them the
same kind of signal so changing that and
tear that for everybody's needs is going
to be critical in sustaining motivation
so this is a beautiful transition to
another question i have for you which is
this notion of what i hear you say is
your feedback has to be different based
on where people are in their journey and
i know you along with our colleague
jennifer ocker have done some research
into
how having a mindset a journey mindset
can actually really influence how you
achieve goals would you share more about
that study i found this
really fundamentally changing for me
personally it was personal for me too
that research finding has a lot of
relevance for how i think about success
and definitely the motivation for that
work it came from the fact that we tend
to think about goal success as a
destination we reach the destination and
we feel great but what happened when you
reach the destination is that there's
nothing else left to be done so a lot of
times people graduate and they stop
learning or they lose weight and so they
stop working out and fundamentally we
want people to continue learning and
continue working out or monitoring what
they eat those good behaviors should
continue so what we found in this
research is that it is important to
think about goal success not just as a
destination but also as a journey it
doesn't actually have to be a journey
forward thinking about the next goal but
it's actually more important to use it
as a journey look to look backwards to
look at what you have done right during
this process that help you achieve the
goal who were instrumental for you
during this journey
well i've enjoyed this very much before
we end i'd like to ask you the same
three questions i ask everyone who joins
me is that okay with you yeah
great then let's get started
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you've ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
it actually already came up earlier in
our talk and i just need three words
know your audience
we have heard that a lot on this podcast
and it and what you bring to that
is
really a lot of depth and richness so
it's about emotionality it's about
understanding that audiences aren't
homogeneous that there there's
differentiations and nuance in there and
to know that they evolve they will
change right over time that journey
that's so important it's not static
excellent thank you
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
i have to say michelle obama and i think
every time i hear her speak there are
four things that comes to mind clarity
confidence elegance and empathy and i
think a speech that has all four
elements are very powerful absolutely
and and you role model some of that
yourself i mean the clarity of the
information that the elegance of the
research that you've done that
excellent choice
number three
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe
so the first one i have to come back to
the same point know your audience
specifically know why they are there to
listen to the message and the second one
would be to tailor your content
connecting your content to that audience
and the third one make it personal you
also have to connect the content to you
so you're not just lecturing something
that they can hear from anybody else
they're actually learning specifically
from you
all three of those are critical i i want
to put an exclamation point after that
personal part because i think that's
something that we don't think about and
sometimes people don't feel comfortable
doing but it really does make a
difference if you feel that the person
has a direct connection to that content
it's meaningful to them thank you for
reminding us of that that's that's
really really important
well thank you suchi this has been
wonderful you have certainly motivated
me to be more interested in motivation
i love your research and how it covers
so many different areas and really makes
us think about who we're talking to
when we're talking to them and how we
can motivate our audience thank you so
much thank you so much for having me
matt
[Music]
you've been listening to think fast talk
smart the podcast a production of
stanford graduate school of business
this episode was produced by mike
o'reilly jenny luna and me matt abrahams
find more resources and join our
conversation
on linkedin by searching think fast talk
smart
please download and subscribe wherever
you get your podcasts